à chercher le corps du pou du corps il
est arrivé le feu
quand a commencé la naissance de le la
après la foulée une histoire autour de
la question du pardon de la
reconstruction du mois la mode qui est
un peu la résilience et de comment ils
décommandent ne peut continuer vise avec
silva traverse un trauma tu vois les
mois une question très importante et un
peu d'actualité en plus malheureusement
avec sa cuisine cette crise de coved
c'est à dire comment une fois que ça
tout ça va finir que nous toutes nos
fenêtres un peu blessée tombée
comment on se retrouve à nous et comment
nous nous recommence à vivre quoi
[Musique]
elle devenue
c'est plus une façon pour moi de poser
des questions ok nous comment nous
comment qui s'annulent et nous par
rapport aux par rapport à la douleur par
rapport au tragique par rapport à la
souffrance
comment commence urines il ne peut
continuer à gardanne où cynophile
famille du mal tu vas entre nous trop
quand j'avais 12 ou que j'ai traîné
partout avec moi pour mon dernier la
mère essaye toujours de là elle ne sais
pas c'est comme un profession de foi mon
affaire là cette façon dit ok mais il
tapa nous d'accord mais il faudra bien
être est il faut faire un dhimmi travail
pour que le moment ils arrêtent plutôt
que de subir lisant dit vous voyez qu'il
est compliqué parce qu'on ne peut pas
rencontre le public maintenant mais mais
il faudra tenir en compte a dit et c'est
ça l'important c'est que de toute façon
nous va trouver continuer de chanter et
mon père ni les sourires
rires me rend folle tuer le père